okay I'm horrific Lee impatient and I
don't have a strong belief in belz is
coming so I think we should just get
going all right so welcome to eat your
vegetables data security for data
scientists hopefully our Bay here is
either a data scientists or is
interested in security or you're in the
wrong room okay we'll just get going
here so first the agenda things are
going to talk about today the agenda
which I know is a little self
referential but we might as well be
complete about this then we're going to
have a little you know introduction who
am i why am I here all that fun stuff
then we're going to have a little talk
about why you're here and hopefully I
can convince you if you're not already
convinced that security is both awesome
and important then we'll get into the
real meat of this whole thing though are
some security concepts this talk is
labeled intermediate mostly because I
didn't want to have to define things so
I'm making some assumptions that you
know the terminology if not I apologize
in advance but there will be time for
questions at the end so help me I will
make sure there's time otherwise you can
always find me on Twitter so we can
follow up after the fact then we'll go
over tools which is the fun stuff
anybody can talk about you know stuff
without actually mentioning solutions so
we'll actually go over tools and then
finally questions and just as a preview
all the slides are online so no need to
scribble furiously during the
presentation you'll be able to get all
this stuff after the fact alright cool i
I'm your speaker ha see it's it's it's
my costume from halloween in 2010 i was
a speaker I'm your speaker it's ok off
to a rough start I actually mounted a
real speaker inside and hooked up to my
phone so i was playing music all night
it was a fantastic time my name is love
or keys by trade I am a software
engineer I don't actually label myself a
data scientist on most days I'm a
software engineer i right boring
security software I've been in the tech
industry for about 15 years give or take
started out doing mostly like computer
repair they went into like network
administration and then landed the whole
software engineering gig it's an IM on
Twitter will 2041 I post a rambling
ramble of tweets so tell me if you want
alright why are we here the great
existential question that we must all
face at some point in our lives but do
that on your own time we're here in this
very room to talk about vegetables
vegetables are awesome they're tasty
your mother has always told you to eat
more vegetables and I thoroughly agree
with that you must eat your vegetables
of course vegetables are you know a
stand-in for security we're actually
here to talk about security why is
security important to you and I hope to
prove to you the vegetables canady be
tasty and if they remember is red vs.
blue this is the opening scene in red
vs. blue fans get what what to really
that's it all right homework everybody
go Google red vs. blue and watch the
first episode otherwise I'd look like a
crazy person with this slide all right
so the great the Great predicate of
everything I'm about to say is that
someone wants your data no I'm very very
serious about that someone wants your
data you might be thinking well duh my
data is awesome of course somebody wants
it that's that's one guy that's probably
true but even if you don't think your
data has value there is somebody out
there that thinks your data is valuable
even Pokemon go accounts have value to
people these days if you just search on
ebay you can buy a Pokemon go account
they have monetary value it's not always
monetary though take the 2015 Ashley
Madison hack as an example teammate not
familiar with that excellent I don't
have to awkwardly explain it then that's
an example of hacktivism the goal was
not monetary in that situation so even
if your data doesn't have monetary value
there is some value to it and why should
you care um well I mean I the obvious
stuff is money about a year ago Lloyd's
insurance put out an estimate that
hacking costs about four hundred billion
dollars a year that's a lot of money
obviously businesses are very
incentivized to not lose that money you
know even nonprofits don't want to lose
the potential value of their data
so everybody knows about that I'm not
going to go into it everybody is
familiar with the money thing but what
other reasons might you really care
about your data and keeping it safe well
compliance HIPAA Sox trade sanctions
government contracts other business
contracts who knows what there are
plenty of legal requirements out there
to keep data safe if you deal with any
sort of data like that you have a vested
interest in security you might also just
care about analytical confidence
encryption and signing especially can
provide a no one touched this guarantee
on your data that's a very nice
out-of-the-box benefit of adding
security you get for free in a lot of
cases and really it avoids that
nightmare situation where you rerun a
model on some data get an entirely
different result in are like um alright
that's great and then you spend weeks
trying to figure out what the devil
happened so security can actually
provide that guarantee that somebody
hasn't gone in and mess with your data
store it's also really fun and no I'm
not kidding I actually enjoy this stuff
security is basically all about puzzles
puzzles are fun there's this concept of
red team and blue team in the security
world attackers and defenders that's
basically one big game have captured the
flag that's fun you might as a kid have
used the Caesar safer to pass messages
back and forth between friends at school
that's where you take the alphabet and
just kind of shift everything by six
letters or twelve letters and then write
out your little code and obviously the
math mind all this stuff is interesting
if you're a math geek and you've never
looked into like what goes into
cryptography look into it it's it's
actually really neat stuff okay you're
gonna be sort of blank board stairs and
you're right you got me all that was
filler those are definitely valid
reasons to care about security but
honestly they are not the most important
reason to care about security in my book
the most secure the most important
reason is trust it's what's for dinner
honestly we're data stewards we deal
with massive amounts of data and people
trust us with that data it doesn't
really matter what the data is somebody
somewhere has trusted you
business maggots trusted you with their
financial data this could be consumer
information health records who knows
what but as data scientists were
ultimately responsible for this data
were the ones working with it every
single day there are not magic
information security elves that are
going to drop down from the sky during a
breach and save our data we have a
vested interest in it and people have
trusted us with it and Trust has a cost
governments can lose national security
the Office of Personnel Management
getting act that was a loss of national
security that wasn't good ecommerce
sites can lose sales but remember that
whole you know money thing that four
hundred billion dollars a years lost
hacking a very recent and I'm talking
like a month ago survey in the journal
cybersecurity actually found that
businesses spend about as much money
defending against hacks as they lose in
an event so from a strict money
standpoint from a business standpoint
it's it looks like it might almost be
awash in terms of defense versus benefit
so maybe money isn't really the biggest
thing here anymore maybe human Trust is
more important Trust is trust of people
is not so nearly easily as quantified
things like Target Ashley Madison their
hat they're still in business are they
doing as well maybe maybe not um and
honestly this is all very murky we don't
actually have a metric yet on how to say
I lost human trust so in the absence of
you know hard data on this I think we
should do what's right protect our data
and protect that trust people have
placed on us so there you go that's the
spiel about why you should care most of
you are still here I only saw one person
leave that's fantastic doing good so
what can we actually do about all this
stuff well I've got some good news and
I've got some bad news the good news
there's easy stuff you can do and it is
really really easy I'm not getting this
stuff is super easy you can add security
with very minimal effort the bad news is
there's also some really really hard
stuff and they're even after you
learn it and know it it's still really
really hard um think heart bleed from
2014 4 openssl the openssl maintainer
czar really smart people they know what
they're doing and an implementation bug
got in there and now suddenly we had
this big heartbleed event where random
memory could be leaked to remote
attackers encryption keys could get lost
and basically everybody was really
really sad so even there you know great
people but it's hard it's hard to get
right so um let's talk about the easy
stuff and hey speaking of heart bleed
you know what she can do that's really
great for keeping your system secure
patch yeah I know it's a pain in the
butt but proactively patching everything
and notice the original version of the
site slide side patch all the server's
not sufficient routers networking
devices IOT devices laptops presenter
remotes basically everything is going to
have a remote vulnerability these days
it seems so just be prepared to patch
everything on your network and if you're
doing it often that's fantastic in the
best case scenario you might apply a
patch for something and then a
vulnerability is discovered in your old
version of whatever package you patched
and hey you're already protected no work
on your part bit to go but even if you
are in the worst-case scenario and some
vulnerability is disclosed and gets a
bunch of media attention and then all
the hackers like oh yeah let's do this
thing if you are passion and
continuously then you know how to do it
you can very quickly get on your systems
and patch the new vulnerability so
patching is just as much about practice
as anything else but beyond patching
some other easy stuff and again I very
much assert that the easy stuff is super
easy and honestly the sad fact of the
matter is so many companies and
organizations have such terrible
security that even just doing these few
basic things are going to put you in a
better security stance then probably
half of the companies out there easy
thing the first access control this is
honestly something that when you're in
the security business you get to a point
where you don't
like you should even need to have to say
this but you do don't leave things open
to the world some restriction is better
than no restriction and so what I mean
by this is put permissions on your
accounts to only be able to do certain
things not running with an admin account
might seem wit like a pain but that can
be the difference between your intern
deleting your data lake or not deleting
your data like so way those two things
accordingly and think about it a bit big
companies are very much guilty of this
i'm going to use nissan as an example so
anybody that drives a Nissan I'm sorry
anybody that drives the Nissan Leaf pay
attention it was discovered that the
nissan leaf has a control system built
into it it can connect to the internet
it will report information about the
vehicle and they'll also let you control
a few things so not the important stuff
like breaking thank goodness but minor
things like what radio station are you
listening to ours your a/c on or is a
blowing heat at you on 95 degree day
that sort of thing it turns out that the
way nissan implemented this control
system for the leaf was 100% open to the
world if you knew the vin number of a
Nissan Leaf you could just get into your
web browser see anything you want about
the car and then start messing with it
no questions asked just 100 sent open
that is terrifying at a minimum that is
just horrible PR for Nissan like a made
from Nissan here do I need to worry
about legal stuff at this point okay
good this was a terrible PR for Nissan
and in the worst case this could have
resulted in loss of life fortunately
they did patch it after it got exposed
but it was an independent researcher
that discovered this vulnerability if
you just add access control now you
don't have to deal with any of this
alright JLS AKA ssl/tls replaced ssl but
everybody calls them the same thing so
if you are talking to somebody and they
say TLS they mean TLS if they're if
you're talking to somebody and they say
ssl they probably mean TLS if they
actually mean ssl that's bad and you
should give them a very stupid look and
ask them why they're still using SSL
it's been deprecated for
a long time in this talk though if I say
SSL I mean TLS so fair warning on that
front for people that don't know what
TLS or SSL is it provides authentication
and encryption on connections the
authentication part comes when you
connect to some things like when you go
in your browser type in HTTPS google com
TLS will give you that assertion yes
this is indeed Google you're connecting
to and not some random attacker and then
the secondary benefit is your connection
is automatically encrypted so any data
you pass back and forth no one just
sitting around in the network and see
that so these are some great features to
have not just in web browsing this
applies for servers talking to other
servers as well but historically TLS has
not been used in a lot of places and the
two biggest reasons now fortunately fall
into the category of myth and legend the
first one was cost it used to be you had
to buy a certificate from a trusted
party to make TLS or SSL work easily
fortunately it is 2016 we have entered
the modern era and let's encrypt as a
thing let's encrypt is a service that
actually will give you pls and ssl
certificates completely for free yes
free zero cost it's amazing no longer do
you have to pay money to be secure they
also provide some really nice
command-line tools that make it easy to
install certificates and update them on
web servers so for any reason you're
running a web server and you've ever
thought to yourself hey it'd be really
cool if I could add SSL now you can do
it for free it's really simple it's
super easy let's encrypt org and I'm a
little embarrassed to admit that it
wasn't until I was preparing this
presentation that the words let's
encrypt actually clicked with me as I'd
like a command for all of us to begin
encrypting I was like oh let's encrypt
that's cool that's nice oh wait it
actually means let's encrypt stuff dude
that's awesome yeah my dog looked at me
like that guy's an idiot the other great
myth is performance for years people
have been like oh no i'm not using TLS
that's going to wreck my performance i
won't be able to perform as quickly as
my performance can perform well not true
um gmail switched over to SSL and when
they did that with no special
optimizations this is just like the most
naive flipping on and see what happens
sort of thing they saw less than one
percent increase in their average cpu
utilization and like milliseconds worth
of latency added so unless you are
actually doing some sort of super high
performance high throughput application
they can't tolerate that level of
additional resource utilization it's
basically free to a TLS to your
connections so highly recommend you give
it a shot experiment with it do a
benchmark see if it applies like I bet
things are going to go well for you okay
account separation and yes yes I know an
avocado is actually a fruit but I
honestly started getting and I got a
little desperate with the vegetable
picture so you get avocados we can deal
with it account separation so this is
really just the idea of using more than
one account lots of people are very keen
you'll get one AWS account or one user
account in your computer and you just do
everything with that cool awesome it's
simple it's also a really bad idea whole
companies have actually been lost like
have gone out of business entirely I'm
thinking of code spaces here
specifically they had one AWS account
for their whole system everything was
running on one AWS account somebody got
the keys to their route eight of us
credentials and deleted everything all
their ec2 instances are gone all their
buckets were cleared out and now you
might be thinking wait what about
backups oh yeah they had backups in the
same AWS account so when there has three
buckets got nuked all their backups got
nuked and they were out of business in
hours it was horrific so use separate
accounts it's a concept of limiting
blast radius if one of your accounts
gets compromised you the attacker can
only do so much so at a minimum just
have a separate backup account that way
you'll have you know relatively safe
backups you can go further with this
your master database user doesn't need
it right access to your s3 bucket so use
a couple different accounts for that
somebody gets into your
BB they can automatically get tall your
s3 buckets and short-lived credentials I
love this one we were talking about this
a little bit before the talk actually so
just like passwords there's this strong
recommendation that all your credentials
or keys to connect other services be
rotated periodically as well so I'm sure
you're used to hearing the change your
password every 90 days maybe it's
enforced at your company same thing with
like a DBS credentials API keys all that
stuff you want to change those
periodically again because it limits the
blast radius if somebody does get your
ate it because credentials well they're
only valid for 30 days so they've only
got 30 days to mess up your stuff that's
a really long time so maybe you want
your credentials to only be valid for
let's say an hour yeah that's still kind
of a long time let's say maybe 15
minutes right all right now we're
getting somewhere 15 minutes to actually
use credentials and do some real damage
starts getting a little bit more tough
so in the AWS land and I'm sorry i
molded bios to AWS so that's kind of my
prime example lots of the services out
there have similar technologies but 80
best land there's this thing called
simple token service it is a service
that will literally give you short-term
credentials and that's fantastic you
really want these short-term credentials
specifically because devs keep putting
those credentials and github like all
the time it's terrifying there was a
talk earlier today where some may popped
up a config file and guess what was at
the top of the file AWS credentials I
could taken a picture I could've done
anything I want on their account that's
not good if you're using short-lived
credentials you don't need to worry
about this as much because by the time
somebody gets to exploiting it they're
probably not valid anymore specifically
with github though because all that's
online there are people out there that
actually run bots that just go through
github looking for AWS keys just sorting
through as soon as they find some they
spin up a bunch ec2 instances and start
doing some free Bitcoin mining and then
you get a three-thousand-dollar AWS bill
I don't think anybody wants that um in
the past you
has actually been pretty good about not
really following through and charging
people when that sort of thing happens
but in general you probably want to
avoid that so you short-lived
credentials reduce your blast radius and
you don't have to deal with Archer memes
ever again all right we're time at the
midpoint can take a little breather get
a sip of water feel free to talk amongst
yourselves no question all right
confirmation from the crowd that those
bills happen right you know we can get
have any who would like to take it down
in later but they're robots yeah yeah
there you go see I'm not just some crazy
person rambling she knows listen to her
okay so at this point I've just been
sprouting general security stuff we're
at PI data for a reason there's probably
some questions about data specifically
so let's talk about that stuff first up
signatures I kind of tease this a little
bit earlier by saying you can have a no
one messed with this guarantee
signatures are the way to do that
signatures are kind of a complement to
encryption encryption will hide data
signatures gives you the ability to
verify data you might also be very
familiar with hashes so what's the
difference between signing and hashing
signing actually proves identity so with
a hash a common example of this is like
you'll see an md5 sum on website with an
iso file for like anna boon to install
or something if a hacker gets on there
they can actually overwrite the whole
file generate a hash and just update the
website with their hash so everything
looks completely legit but it's not
somebody is messed with the data using a
signature there is a secret key that
gets thrown into the mix so unless the
attacker also knows the secret key they
cannot generate a valid signing a valid
signature for whatever malicious data
they put on there so this is really
great um and if you attach signatures to
your data or to any of like any sort of
like analysis you've done on the data
you can actually have over time this
guarantee that nothing has been messed
with so it's really great but speaking
of encryption encryption it solves
everything we're done
no I'm obviously kidding that's not true
at all people love to think the
encryption is the end-all be-all of
security slap some encryption on it oh
yeah got you know I got some dan I wanna
keep saying further slaps encryption on
I'm good ya know it's not easy we're
definitely getting into the this is
really hard part of the conversation now
encryption is difficult to do right the
there are actually a couple of concepts
in encryption confidentiality and
integrity confidentiality is just that
hidden data thing so you don't want
anybody to see your data alright they
can't see it you've got confidentiality
integrity is you don't want any way to
mess with your data or if they do you
wanna know about it and even in just the
encryption world AES advanced encryption
standard just using AES to encrypt
something may or may not provide
integrity depending on which mode you
use so if that's super confusing now you
know why this is hard you have to be
very specific and your encryption to
make sure it's done right and
unfortunately there's way more to this
than I could ever cover in this talk so
I'm afraid that if you want to learn
about the specific ins and outs and guts
of the various encryption schemes you're
gonna have to Google you have to read
some books up cryptography engineering
design principles and practical
applications comes highly recommended
for sort of a boots on the ground you
know more practical approach to using
some of these schemes so you'll have to
go check into that on your own because
there are a few other challenges we need
to talk about encrypted data is a pain
it's always going to be slower it's just
the state of the world some tools are
just absolutely gonna freak out at the
thought of trying to deal with encrypted
data bye-bye grep cat basically anything
use on the command line it's not going
to work on encrypted data so really we
have to work with unencrypted data but
the trick is we need to work with it in
a safe controlled way so once you've got
your encrypted data pulled down from
wherever it's stored decrypt it because
you're going to have to to work with it
there are very very few tools that will
work directly with encrypted data they
do exist again Google you're not going
to go into it too much but most
simplistic alee if you just decrypt your
data and work with it alright that's
awesome the tooling question goes away
but here are the tricks
keep it unencrypted for a short of a
time as possible as soon as you're done
with it throw it out delete it get on
memory or just rhian cryptid do whatever
just get rid of it as soon as you're
done using it do everything you can to
avoid writing it to disk logging
especially is the biggest trap in the
world for data if you log stuff you
could actually be logging unencrypted
sensitive data and now it's in your log
system is your lock system encrypted
probably not so watch out for that sort
of thing tooling can help with this but
it requires effort and we're going to
talk about tooling Orion going to talk
about some of the effort required but
remember back to that whole thing about
how companies can go out of business if
they're lacks on security keep that in
mind a little bit of investment to the
tooling to prevent massive data breaches
or complete company collapses is
probably worth it assuming you like
where you work and if not then I guess
not but you know at least think about it
a key management is also a pain more
data actually equals more keys this is
kind of a new concept to some people as
you're encrypting stuff new data should
eventually start using new keys again we
go back to the concept of blast radius
if an encryption key has been leaked do
you want that to mean all of your data
is visible or maybe only half your data
a quarter of your data maybe even just
one piece of data gets leaked if an
encryption key goes rogue so over time
you should actually be changing up your
encryption keys encrypting new data with
it but this means that because you
probably want to access old data now you
have to keep an ever-growing set of keys
around to be able to encrypt new data
and decrypt the old data when you need
it also don't keep your keys next to
your encrypted data one s3 bucket with a
bunch of like data files encrypted key
for data file that doesn't help anybody
I keep your encrypted data somewhere
else with your keys to separate s3
buckets is great and then the real trick
to this whole thing is when you're
keeping keys in a different place you
need a pointer to them so you don't
forget if you just have an s3 bucket
full of blobs with no reference to what
key was used to encrypt
okay good luck that's a rough situation
to be in fortunately like s3 actually
provides the ability to attach metadata
every blob you upload that metadata is a
great place to put a reference to the
key so you can say hey I use key serial
for to encrypt that data um yeah so key
management is a pain um have i bummed
you out yet are you sad yes I'm seeing
some smiles but mostly sad sad faces and
yes I realize that's not a vegetable
this is an aside if you search for the
term vegetable on flickr that image has
the vegetable tag so tag appropriately
please you'll make you'll make of
presenters way happier not finding pig
pictures okay pigs aside what can we
actually do about this stuff so remember
those few tips do decrypt your data but
be safe about it don't keep it around
get rid of the unencrypted version as
quickly as possible don't log it
anywhere you don't watch out for that
stuff if you can split it up what are
the odds you're going to have to have
your entire data set loaded in at any
given time if you're only dealing with a
few fields in your data set actually
slice the data into keep one set here
one side here and then the amount of you
encrypted data you're dealing with goes
down by half just instantly so there are
some strategies there depending on what
you're doing you might be able to only
encrypt part of your data to work
without any given time you might just be
able to work with metadata instead of
actual data that could be an option
that's fantastic you're seeing a theme
here getting encryption out the picture
makes your life easier but at the
expense of you know now you're not using
encryption but then use the tools and
that's what we're going to move into now
Jules everybody loves tools and
fortunately we're not alone in this
there are lots of people out there
they're very very interested in security
so there are people out there that will
help you with tooling um the only thing
I can really say on some tooling is do
not roll your own crypto that's the term
for writing up your own encryption
library or scheme you might think it's
great to like encrypt something twice
yeah well there are certain cases we're
actually encrypting something twice
makes it less secure than encrypting
something once so try to stick to the
standards don't come up with your own
schemes will all be happier for it but
some high-level tools so there's this
con there's this new thing JWT JSON web
token it's kind of new it's mostly for
like server to server communication
stuff but it's really nice because the
standards provide great ways to do
encryption on jason or jason if you
prefer and yes my last name is where
he's Jason Voorhees friday 13th I've
heard it all we don't need to go into it
and then there's this specifically
Python I don't know how they want to say
this Jose or Jose jo se is JavaScript
object signing and encryption and they
specifically implement some of the JWT
features now this does signing but not
actually encryption so it's sort of
imprecisely named but that whole you
know nobody has touched us to guarantee
as talking about if you've got a bunch
of Jason sitting around and you just
want to throw a signature on it this
library makes it really really simple
like really simple like that's it that's
how you generate a signature with this
yeah so the the ad is the the bit that's
getting signed for anybody that doesn't
spot that so super easy tool um but
that's really high level what if we want
to do this powerful like you know deep
security encryption stuff we got a
couple of options on that too pi crypto
and PI openssl this is very low level so
we're just kind of stepping down the
stack on this stuff these both provide
all the basic cryptographic primitives
you need to do literally anything like
these are the power lifters of the
Python security library world just the
world is your oyster you can encrypt you
can sign you can just go nuts with these
they expose all sorts of different
encryption schemes different key
generation techniques you can do TLS
stuff with this work with certificates
public-private key stuff asymmetric
symmetric encryption like the feature
list is just gigantic but they're also
terrifying I wouldn't want to touch
either of these with a ten-foot pole
they're scary they give you too much
power it's too easy to mess stuff
so let's go back up the stack a little
bit and find something a bit more human
friendly cryptography it's so perfectly
named I can't even begin to tell you
this is actually a package that's
written by the same people that do PI
openssl so they know what they're doing
and the goal here is to have human
friendly cryptography so if you want to
encrypt some data that's it just like
four lines like it's nothing this is
pretty secure this will use a es 128-bit
keys under the hood which is basically
the de facto standard for cryptography
so it's very secure and it's super
simple you've got a key that you just
need to store somewhere somewhere you
don't keep your encrypted data mind you
and then your token is your encrypted
data so that's it like this stuff is
super easy and this is a fairly secure
solution unless you've got very specific
regulatory reasons to use different
crypto schemes this will do a great job
at getting you on the security board
okay I feel like I need to talk about
pickles just because they're so popular
and I like pickles but you need to be
very very very careful with the big
balls see how I got silent in traumatic
they're piggles are an exploit waiting
to happen this is a this is an example
from Travis Cunningham in the I know
it's reduced but I'm just going to call
it the unpickable method because it's
easier to think about for me that will
actually execute code so when you unpick
all this you know it does subprocess p
open and lists out whatever contents of
the directory here and if this was a
malicious pickle it could do anything it
wants to your box so that's scary
fortunately there are very easy
mitigations sign your pickles there's
that signing thing again unless you're
putting remote code exploitation xin
your pickles for some reason when you
generate a pickle sign it validate that
signature before actually unpick lling
it you're good to go and also you use
TLS wins sending pickles around makes
your life easier so I'm going to trust
you through this real quick because I'm
running out of time and I really wanna
make sure there's time for questions but
I would be remiss if I didn't at least
briefly discuss providers I talked a
little bit about some AWS stuff
unfortunately these examples are
bbs oriented again but hey a lots of
different providers have similar
capabilities and features so just look
around the documentation for your
preferred cloud provider or not cloud
provider as the case may be and you'll
probably find something very similar a
server-side encryption is a very nice
feature that s 3 provides where it will
encrypt your data with a key that it
manages before it puts it on hard drive
somewhere this is great for regulatory
compliance that says you must encrypt
your data at rest you can literally add
a bucket policy to your s3 bucket and
any put is automatically encrypted and
saved any get is decrypted and then
returned to you so it's great for
checking off boxes on form it does mean
you're still trusting Amazon with all of
your keys though and Amazon does have
the ability to look at your data so
maybe that's okay maybe it's not you'll
have to think about it but it is an
option if you're really paranoid though
you want to use client-side encryption
nice little s3 library this will
actually do the encryption of your data
before it gets sent s3 so you give the
you give it a key and some data it
encrypts it and then sends it off to s 3
s 3 does not see your data it cannot
decrypt it for you if the data gets
pulled out via an attacker they have
encrypted blobs I can't do anything with
it the only problem I have with this is
that it's not as future rich as I'd
really like if you actually look at the
Amazon provided Java amazon s3
encryption client the future set there
ah it is great that is a down that's a
library and it makes me so sad to say
that but the feature said in the Java
library they provide is fantastic so um
while this is a great start we can do
better and this is actually a great
proof of concept that like you can
actually combine the boto library and
these low-level cryptography libraries
and get very very powerful tooling out
the deal and if you can build security
into the tool to make it as transparent
as possible it makes everybody happy
last thing we'll talk about key
management service key management
services at amazon service that does all
of your key management it's very well
named
basically if you need to keep it gives
you a key if you need to get a key to
decrypt some data it gives you the
appropriate key that's it you can wrap
that around your data access or library
and now all of your encryption is a
hundred percent transparent again the
java sdk is more full-featured yeah you
know it's it is what it is ok so very
quickly because I'm running out of time
and this is crammed full very
interesting stuff remember security is
important trust is literally priceless
so for no other reason do this because
people trust you with their data do the
basics they're better than nothing
Python does have tons security tools way
more than I mentioned here go check it
out google around a bit like Google
Python security and you'll get a ton of
results and providers can help if a
private er doesn't have a security
feature you want talk to them they
probably have lots of customers asking
for it and your input will make it more
likely they'll provide that for people
in the future ok I'm done I know you're
thinking thank goodness he is done with
this whole thing he's done speaking i do
want thank you this is the first time
i've done a presentation like this this
is my inaugural presentation so you guys
have been great thank you very much i
also need to just talk about district
data labs you're probably hearing about
them a lot this weekend they are a data
science research group based at DC I'm
actually from the west coast they're my
East Coast compatriots they're doing
talks in this room all day tomorrow at
like 1130 115 and three on various
topics so i recommend you know coming
out listen to them talk about all that
fun stuff they are working on all right
and that's it slides are already online
there's bitly link but if you don't
trust it because it's a bit ly Lincoln
who knows where it's going this is the
full URL good luck I didn't have any say
in what it was yeah so let us go out on
a high note with some questions
go ahead don't be shy oh yes this
example district under collection let's
say a jamaica key save it and creep it
use the current stand up right right and
then one way one year later yes so the
question was what happens if i use one
of these cryptography libraries and it
uses a given encryption scheme and then
a year later I go to decrypt my data and
the standard encryption scheme has
changed I've upgraded the package and
it's doing something different now
unfortunately I'm not a hundred percent
sure on this so take it with a grain of
salt but if they're doing things right
there's this concept of envelope
encryption where you can attach metadata
about how the encryption was done to the
into the encrypted blob so in that
situation the scheme that was used for
the encryption is available for whatever
library is handling the decryption
scheme and as long as they haven't
changed their interface horribly
substantially it should still be able to
fall back to an older scheme at that
point you might want to ask yourself if
you then want to re-encrypt it with a
newer scheme and generate new data but
by and large a lot of libraries will be
good about the backwards up application
like that adds totally doable I just
can't give you a firm yes that these
libraries do that
any other questions oh yes just as area
how to explain side encryption to AWS
for sending excellence a screen you
can't really do that in here with
uploading to RDS event show yeah so the
question is the example of encrypting
data before putting an s3 and the
observation you can't really do it with
some things like RDS redshift yeah
that's very true a lot of services in
Amazon do not know how to deal with
encrypted data appropriately they
there's more and more integration
happening with the key management
service I talked about and these
services that will do encrypted data but
only internally so the ingestion to the
system has to be unencrypted but then
internally it will use KMS to encrypt it
so it's it's encrypted at rest but you
have the question how do I get it in
there securely and so there are things
like TLS maybe it's capable of reading
from an encrypted s3 bucket a few
different options on that front okay
that's time so thank you very much